[Música]
bem eu vim aqui falar um pouco sobre meu
trabalho como agente chegou aonde chegou
com aberta que esse robô permite que
sejam entender um pouco melhor mas antes
eu queria porque tem que conversar e se
refletir em uma outra forma sobre
tecnologia
o meu tema hoje é como a tecnologia
impacta positivamente a vida das pessoas
e comunidades
quando a gente pensa tecnologia avança
código algoritmos homem na lua sei lá
televisão mini e quando eu comecei a
trabalhar com tecnologia eu fiz relações
internacionais na faculdade trabalhei
com direitos humanos então nem filtro do
instagram se usar muito bem e eu fiquei
pensando cara e agora que a gente vai
fazer né
estou comprando tecnologia os braços e
comecei a entender e buscar o que era de
verdade tecnologia e acabei adotando a
origem da palavra pra quem não sabe a
tecnologia vem do grego antigo tanque
que significa técnica e logo que
significa é argumento discussões razões
e aí você consegue tirar uma noção de
tecnologia que é basicamente uma
ferramenta um instrumento meio não é o
fim de nada
é um conjunto de conhecimentos que a
gente usa para atender de maneira
prática alguma necessidade das pessoas
é a gente precisa usar é o conjunto de
conhecimentos pra conseguir mudar o
mundo agir de alguma forma que a gente
consegue impactar de maneira prática a
vida das pessoas bem com essa tecnologia
a gente pode pensar nas gambiarras a
gente no brasil
saca muito de gambiarra então se você
faz um suporte de filmagens em com cano
de pvc essa tecnologia se você
transforma uma caixinha de fósforo no
projetor isso a tecnologia eu trabalhei
durante um tempo na índia ea gente foi
com os alunos de serviço social para uma
vila rural para entender quais eram as
questões como é que a gente podia ajudar
a melhorar a vida deles basicamente como
usar nossos conhecimentos nossas
tecnologias para melhorar aquela
comunidade o principal problema é que
tinha um índice de estupro muito alto
entre as meninas e as mulheres e aí foi
um grupo de universitários na pensando
carente pode criar um botão do pânico no
celular e daí a menina vai aperta e vai
notificar uma autoridade policial
hoje pode fazer uma oficina com os
homens porque eles vão ser menos
violento com as mulheres até que a gente
resolveu na comunidade porque a gente
não pode simplesmente querer dar uma
solução para uma pessoa que a gente nem
conhece por um estilo de vida que não é
o nosso é que a gente não está próximo
e aí uma solução que a gente chegou foi
justamente construir mais banheiros uma
solução simples uma tecnologia simples
não é nada fora do normal mas a gente
entendeu que o grande problema é que os
banheiros nas comunidades rurais da
índia ficam muito afastados dos centros
de onde as pessoas estão morando então
quando as meninas faziam o trajeto à
noite elas eram atacadas isso óbvio não
resolve o problema é dos homens serem
violentas do machismo da cultura mas de
alguma forma a gente conseguia melhorar
a vida daquelas mulheres
agora que a gente tenha essa nova um
pouco mais ampla sobre o que a
tecnologia sobre esse conjunto de
conhecimentos que a gente usa para
transformação de maneira prática eu vou
falar do nosso eu vou falar da beta o
nosso e se define como uma um
laboratório de ativismo e eu posso falar
pra vocês que é uma ong e talvez seja
mais fácil de entender
mas o que a gente faz é basicamente é
buscar formas de engajar as pessoas na
política ea gente faz o uso
especialmente da tecnologia para isso
a gente sabe que a nossa representação e
participação política super desigual
então a tecnologia ela acaba sendo uma
ferramenta para você superar várias
barreiras porque é que pode uma
audiência pública de hoje à tarde na
câmara quem é que consegue entender o
que um ministro do stf está dizendo o
quanto ele vota quem é que consegue de
fato mobilizar tantas pessoas é no boca
a boca tudo bem isso já foi feito
algumas vezes mas a gente está hoje
vivendo uma outra sociedade ea
tecnologia é uma aliada a gente
conseguir chegar mas há mais
oito de fato engajar as pessoas no
ativismo político no que importa para a
vida delas bem e um laboratório de
ativismo significa que a gente vai
experimentar então a gente não tem
respostas a gente não tem certo ou
errado a gente vai inovar as vezes que
não vai renovar e vezes a gente vai
errar ea gente vai entender porque a
gente errou e vai trabalhar para fazer
melhor
daí é aí que entra a beta ano passado em
abril a gente estava tendo uma conversa
e eu sou feminista e construiu vários
espaços de mulheres alguns anos e aí a
gente estava percebendo que muitos
retrocessos estavam sendo pautados no
congresso nacional
muitos avanços estavam sendo pautados no
supremo tribunal federal e tem um monte
de organização feminista que exista 20 e
30 anos do brasil que está por dentro
disso tudo que está lá todo dia no
congresso nacional de olho que está
votando contra as mulheres quem está
votando a favor que tá lá fazendo
petição para colocar no judiciário para
as mulheres poderem ter algum direito
garantido e essas discussões raramente
chegam às pessoas como por comuns porque
realmente não é a linguagem política é a
lógica política ela não é acessível
inclusive para as pessoas que estão lá
dentro muitas vezes e aí eu falei para a
gente está com vários projetos de lei
que estão quase passando vão tirar
vários direitos das mulheres
a gente tem o máximo o stf pode aumentar
os direitos das mulheres e tem uma
galera massa de olho nisso mas a gente
também tem uma outra galera massa que
está no facebook e transformando o
feminismo no fenômeno e numa no momento
transformar no feminismo de fato uma é
com uma força que ele não tinha em
outros momentos graças à informação às
tecnologias a gente tenha de mulheres no
facebook fazendo questão sobre feminismo
ter mulheres no facebook criando grupos
de solidariedade entre mulheres
a gente teve no youtube fazendo vídeo ou
assistindo vídeos de mulheres então de
fato o feminino feminismo foi muito
beneficiado pela tecnologia e pela era
da informação e pelas redes sociais e
com todas as críticas e com todas as
questões né
às vezes fica um debate meio vazio às
vezes fica um debate de ódio mas é um
lugar que de fato
faleceu a luta das mulheres então a
gente pensou bem precisamos fazer essa
ponte precisa usar todo esse potencial
em 2015 vai acontecer na primavera das
mulheres no rio de janeiro
as mulheres organizaram um evento no
facebook de repente não 100 mil na rua
button projeto de lei e começar a
colocar pra elas de maneira acessível
essas pautas que impactam dia a dia
delas bem marcamos uma reunião
o nosso tem uma equipe de tecnologia
porque quando a gente fala que a gente é
um laboratório de ativismo e usa
tecnologia como maneira de engajar
pessoas têm uma equipe que queria
ferramentas que tornam tudo isso
possível
aí essa foi uma daquelas reuniões que
você senta e todo mundo parece que tá
meio convergindo tem uma energia louca e
surgiu aberta eu falei olha precisamos
mobilizar redes sociais
a gente pode articular com essa galera
ea gente pode fazer um monitoramento do
que está rolando ea gente faz uma
linguagem legal a gente usa tecnologia
do meio por exemplo a gente usa
tecnologia de envio de e mail para
autoridades
a gente vai conseguir fazer com que o
debate chegue a essas mulheres
e aí galera de tecnologia falou á o
facebook lançou um chat bote a gente
pode experimentar a colocar a função de
pressão política dentro do chat bote e
aí todo mundo corre piada falou então
vamos fazer no facebbok feminista e
assim nasceu aberta bem
agora vou conseguir ficar e talvez
mostrar pra vocês é como que funciona
aberta um chat bote nada mais é do que
um programa de computador que simula uma
conversa uma conversa entre pessoas
no caso da beta ela existe no facebook é
uma página do facebook que você clica
naquele botãozinho ali embaixo da etapa
e ela começa a mandar mensagens e pelos
botões você vai conversando com ela ela
também tem inteligência artificial e
significa perguntar pra ela aberta que
horas são
ela vai responder mentira que horas são
não as pessoas perguntam mas ela não
responde porque só tem um relógio lina
tipo mas se você quiser perguntar aberto
e que esse mesmo negro beck que é uma
proposta de emenda constitucional vai
até me fale sobre marielly aberta vai te
responder
então você tem essas duas opções de
conversa e qualquer lance da beta
todo mundo que conversa com ela sabe
o que está acontecendo sobre o direito
das mulheres no brasil e sempre que tem
alguma campanha no ar alguma coisa que
precisa da mobilização das pessoas a
gente consegue através da beta mandar
uma mensagem em boxe pra todo mundo que
está no seu celular e recebe um alerta
da beta flandoli galera daqui a duas
horas vão votar uma pec quer tirar o
direito ao aborto em caso de estupro
a gente precisa fazer nossa voz chegar
nessa qualidade do que aberta permite
que você conversando com ela envia um
e-mail de pressão para as autoridades
que são capazes de decidir sobre aquele
caso a gente lançou uma campanha da peta
no ano passado contra a pec 81 que tinha
justamente o propósito de acabar com o
direito ao aborto legal no brasil em
caso de estupro e risco de vida para a
mãe ea gente fez exatamente isso a gente
vê uma mensagem para 50 mil pessoas que
falaram com ela e pediram para elas
darem os e mails dela aberta explica que
ela iria enviar para caixa de entrada de
e mail de cada deputado ou deputada
o resultado foi que 34 mil pessoas
enviaram emails então cada deputado
recebeu 34 mil e mails o que é chato por
um lado porque você trava a caixa de
entrada se recebe ligação de assessor
parlamentar falando então há uma semana
não entra mais nada só vocês
a gente fala ah tudo bem você pode
posicionar contra o projeto de lei votar
conta que a gente retira o teu nome
daniel sem problemas
e por outro lado né você gera um
burburinho você atrai a opinião pública
todo mundo fala cara que quem está um
robô que eu vou fazer meu chegar mas já
estou conversando com ela e por outro
lado eu acho que o que é mais legal da
beta é que de fato torna esse processo
de participação muito mais fácil é
simples
e quando a gente lançou essa tecnologia
a gente passou a cara muito legal estão
roubou chat bote poder avisar em tempo
real
mantenha as mulheres ligadas mas além da
tecnologia própria do chat bote é uma
tecnologia digital que eu por exemplo
tenho acesso e acho que a maioria das
pessoas que não têm esse conhecimento
técnico não tem acesso
a gente pensou que outros conjuntos de
conhecimentos vamos transformar aberta
de fato no poder transformador e ali há
tantas mulheres nas redes
na luta por seus direitos aberta ela tem
que ser agradável embora tem que ser
bonita tem que ser chamativa tem que ser
popular porque ninguém vai querer
interagir com o robô que num é maneira
não faz muito sentido redes sociais é
sobre estatuto também então aberta é
fofa já atualizada pois podem entrar na
página dela e ver que mudou algumas
coisas ea gente passou por gente vai
falar de política e política não é
acessível e política para muita gente é
chato e ninguém sabe o que é a
tramitação que é a obstrução de pauta o
que é pec que é a dpf
então a gente tem que fazer uma tradução
desse política é este e aberta não pode
ser séria porque se ela for séria as
pessoas das redes sociais que estão
falando na linguagem dos membros que
estão falando nas gírias da internet vão
falar nossa que sapo isso então aberta
tem um tom de voz tem uma personalidade
que a descontraída a linguagem dele é
simples ela usa gírias a hashtag ela usa
gif da grécia
então a gente consegue alguma forma
dialogar com o público que está lá a
laura mas é o facebook né o facebook as
mulheres estão lá mesmo que a gente
quisesse inventar um aplicativo de
pressão mesmo que a gente quisesse
inventar uma outra rede social
a gente precisaria chegar nas mulheres e
onde aquela estão no facebook
a beta 8 no facebook mas ela pode fazer
essa função em outros aplicativos como
allegran enfim o que mais a gente
conseguir
cansado a grande questão é que quando a
gente pensou na aberta e ela foi pro
mundo bem antes do que a gente imaginava
a gente começou a valorizar receber
muitos apoios muitas mensagens falando
nosso tom de voz é legal aberta
engraçada divertida mas até por dentro
então a nossa grande lição foi cara a
tecnologia ela a digital especialmente
nela é muito importante mas eu tenho um
robô se ninguém entende o que ele vai
falar eu tenho um robô se eu não fizer
uma articulação com o movimento
feminista porque está ligado no que está
acontecendo que eu era uma pessoa
imagina você desce negócios e meio todos
que entram de proposta todo dia só no
congresso ele é um pai duro que é muita
coisa
a gente não vê mas acontece então um
grande aprendizado que a gente teve
coberta foi justamente que a tecnologia
digital por se ela não vai ser o que vai
garantir o sucesso de nadal não é um fim
é o meio de fato para você conseguir um
objetivo e têm outras formas outro
conjunto de conhecimentos que são tão
fundamentais quanto o conhecimento
digital
você não precisa inventar nada novo e
estar lá no facebook facebook te deixa
fazer chat botes em você nem precisa
saber programar mas por que será que a
gente conseguiu tanto impacto tanto a
pressão foi só porque ela era um robô é
também porque é um robô mas também
porque a gente fez um trabalho longo de
articulação
a gente faz um trabalho diário de
monitoramento a gente fez uma pastoral
para aberta porque a gente queria que
ela tivesse uma personalidade bem
definido então é taurina
mas tem coisas em peixes e sim uma
panela é maneiro
isso tudo é para dizer pra vocês que
quando a gente gosta um projeto assim no
mundo
a gente não tem certeza que vai dar a
gente atualizou a foto de capa da beta
ea gente estava com ela pronta ela
estava em construção a gente chama de
roboi aprendiz e à internet descobriu a
gente não sabe como até hoje em 24 horas
20 mil pessoas já tinham conversado com
ela eu estava super burrinho ainda não
sabem tem de responder algumas coisas e
aí mas as pessoas se entenderam e se
identificaram tanto com ela e falaram
para eu precisava disso eu preciso de
alguém que vai melhorar
tá que tem alguma coisa rolando que eu
posso fazer é mobilizar e executada de
uma maneira prática e eu gosto de poder
entender o que está acontecendo
eu gosto de poder entender o que é uma
pec como é que isso vai impactar a minha
vida como eu posso fazer
às vezes o envio de meios de pressão é
melhor tecnologia para uma campanha
às vezes você fala usar aberta para
achar mais mulheres pra ir pra rua vai
ser uma tecnologia muito mais eficiente
o nosso aprendizado descoberta é
contínuo ela continua uma robô aprendiz
é agora hoje especialmente a gente está
divulgando através da beta pelas ações
que vão acontecer em torno da marelli e
eu acho que nesse dia especialmente é a
mensagem da beta de que a coletividade é
o que de fato móveis estruturas é ainda
mais forte
então chamei aberta no box é mandei um
oi para ela
mandei moyses ela responde hoje e se
vocês quiserem enfim mandar sugestões
acham que a gente poderia falar de algum
assunto aberta levitt pra isso e eu
espero que ninguém tenha medo de códigos
e algoritmos porque a tecnologia é muito
além disso então a gente pode usar nosso
favor em em outras situações
é isso obrigado a entrar
[Aplausos]
[Música]